the middle of all this misery and loss
in southeast texas the human spirit is
shining through because so many people
are stepping up to help their neighbors
officials say they've actually had to
turn some volunteers away demarco morgan
is in houston with some of the moments
that brought joy and light during an
awful week demarco good morning
good morning maurice it has been a tough
week but we have proof that in times
like fees there are good people ready to
help
and a week of ordinary people stepping
up as heroes a superhero spends some
everyday cheer
i came down here because
i saw there was a need for
people to just volunteer and do what
they can to kind of improve morale and i
think that's one of the most important
things that we need to work on
is trying to help build morale while
we're
here this is definitely the most
important thing i've done as spider-man
is to get out here with the people who
are truly in need
out here where hundreds line up not
seeking help but hoping to lend a hand i
don't want to ask you a star i want to
answer your joy a trim a shave and a
moment of normalcy for the flooded and
the first responders
i wasn't hit as bad and it would be kind
of me to go out and help others that
were hurt feel better about yourself the
way you look your appearance although
we're going through some
bad times hard times right now
i feel compelled to carry on trapped by
high water for two days bakers turned 4
thousand pounds of flour into free food
for the soul
at a shelter an impromptu birthday party
for a girl born 12 years ago during
katrina
at a moment of need pizza delivered by
kayak to the stranded and hungry
and gospel singers spreading a message
of love and hope raising spirits and
shelters across a city
with a long road to recovery i was
raised to be a good person you help your
neighbors you help the stranger who
needs help because one day you're going
to be at the end other end of that stick
and you're going to need somebody's help
and so you put it out there and goodness
comes back to you and let it be a sweet
sweet
sound
in
your ear
my mother always says you have to watch
how you put your shoes on in the morning
because you never know who's gonna have
to help you take them off in other words
be kind to everyone and that's exactly
what we saw right here in texas gail boy
demarco i like your mom saying that's
great that's great and very appropriate
that's a good lesson for all of us to
remember regardless of what you're going
through very nice so we like the gospel
music go ahead somebody said that
somebody tweeted at me that we saw the
best in texas as opposed to what we saw
in charlottesville a couple of weeks ago
this is what america is all about makes
you feel good gives you a boost keeps it
all in perspective